[Music]
so there's a group of people out there
[ __ ] them [ __ ] them all
no literally these okay these people
they're going out and they're
contracting the piranhas on purpose and
then they have an orgy party literally a
corona party Oh what their concept their
idea is they are thinking that if they
get it then it'll be fine because you
know they'll recover and then they'll
have the immunity now is that how it
works
no cuz I heard that you can get it again
yeah that's what I heard that's why
people are saying it's a horrible idea
because we don't even have the vaccine
or like we don't even have anything like
you just have to go through it and we
don't know what your body's gonna react
to it like people don't know if your
lungs are gonna stop working really well
yeah cuz young people are dying too yeah
and that's exactly what they're saying
here is that some people are just just
like they have really small symptoms
like diarrhea or whatever right but
there's people that are literally dying
and there's nothing we can do because we
don't have the cure for it that sounds
like a terrible party diarrhea at a
party coughing at a party what what the
[ __ ] fevers at a party that's like I
wish people would get it and like get
hurt go away but no but then they could
spread it you know that's the thing yeah
Darwinism at its finest yeah but then
they [ __ ] us up that's the problem and I
was [ __ ] themselves up right do they
leave the house like do they have their
Corolla so they have a little what do
you call it like a like a it's called
like a exposure party or something like
okay yeah and then they get together but
they don't know how they [ __ ] do it
or whatever but this is a communist
circle people are swearing that the
immunity is a sure thing but they're
saying it's not so you got to [ __ ]
think about it right not a scientist or
a doctor don't think you have this if
they did this and like Gio was saying
they just stay in the house for a month
straight because they're not affecting
anyone [ __ ] you yeah just stay there for
at least a month after you do this and
Julia's you're right about the
reinfection could be possible it
like the long-term consequences of the
whole virus no one really knows yet
because it's just happening right now
right so it could continue living inside
you even for a while well I know that
there would be like residual damage
because there's a doctor in China who
did get who did get the virus and he did
like an MRI on his lungs are you doing
scan on his lungs and he just saw like a
big black dot on it fog and then as soon
as he recovered he decided to like
rescan himself again to see if that dot
was still there and it was still was
there and then he like did it again like
a couple months later and like it would
just went down like just a little bit
but it was still dead it takes a long
time for your lungs to get rid of stuff
mm-hmm whoa because if I get it x-rayed
it might be the mess from high school
yeah I don't know but I do want to get
checked though cuz I had a crazy cough
earlier this year and I don't know don't
go now cuz and if you didn't have it
you're gonna get it for sure so yeah
they're saying here that even the young
can be hospitalized so don't be stupid
man why would you do this
maybe they blame last-man-standing you
know just like last person stay alive
wins the game maybe they can be the cure
you know because uh a big thing that
people are starting to do now is they're
getting blood plasma from people who've
had the corona virus I think the same
thing that and then oh but then
injecting that into older people who are
currently sick
so because you developed antibodies and
now it's in your blood they take that
and then actually to people who are
currently sick and it helps fight it off
any older we watched a video yesterday
where were they were they were thinking
that maybe California had early exposure
because of like the millions of Chinese
folks that come over and visit and so it
could have been early as the fall
because what we're seeing is like for a
population as big as our state we should
be seeing more deaths more people sick
whatever but we don't and so right now
in NorCal I think Stanford is doing a
study on people to see if they have the
antibodies to kovat 19 and they're doing
like a finger prick and
King and they're finding out that like
there are people who already have a
resistance to it so that might be what
they're doing there too is like you know
getting the blood from people that
already got it and they recovered and in
like giving it to other people yeah yeah
it started to happen on a bigger scale
right now there cuz it was this one
woman she's a doctor
her dad's a doctor too and he got it so
the first thing she did right away was
post on Twitter and was like hey who had
coronavirus and got better and then can
you also donate your blood and a bunch
of people who came in they're like oh I
can help you I can help you I got
coronavirus yeah certain they were able
to just like a few days ago one person -
from two hours away drove all the way
there cuz their blood type matched and
then they were able to donate so maybe
that's a better idea than a cough party
yeah why don't these people donation can
you go can you just carve into my mouth
sure you know these people just wait
until the vaccine or the proper stuff is
already in the works right like aren't
they working like on a malaria that
cures malaria none of that is proven
it's not but I mean the testing is
happening but like why go through
getting sick just to go through it now
why not just be safe until they come out
with a stuff or like device but then
they're like oh well I live in fear if I
already got it I'm good I can do
whatever the [ __ ] I want after they
because they don't know that they could
actually get sick sick I think that's
what people don't get it's like it's not
about you getting sick it's about you
can get somebody weak sick and bacon
died did you guys see the [ __ ] meme
with all the matches that are catching
up firing that one little brave match
you walk so out of the line it matches
and you've the fire stops yeah I don't
think they're idea is how much they
affect other people they're just like
when can I just do [ __ ] again we're just
dumb how do I protect myself yeah I
don't know man this whole thing is kind
of [ __ ] up people from the world whoa
sweet Julius Julia the problem that
they're crowding our hospitals Julia
Zoe's sweet you if they're intentionally
just getting sick so that they can get
over it without having to be
hospitalized and you might tip man
fate is in your hands luck is by your
side like we'll see we'll see if you
survive what happened to the hospital I
would agree to that I wish that those
people just rid themselves off but the
problem with that is they're also
infecting other people yeah that's the
problem I'm just saying that if it's
contained like what you were saying in
the scenario things like stay in the
house all together and be infected wait
a year maybe two maybe five the two that
are doing this aren't that smart to
steal like if that was the case like why
don't you go to a [ __ ] STD party
[ __ ] bengi fever party or like a
malaria party or like whatever like why
I don't get STDs like in certain parts
of the world yeah and it's pretty bad go
there and catch that yeah the [ __ ] I
don't know and it's different too
because when you're getting it when
you're when people are contagious like
that's when you're really getting it
sick versus like the doctors at the
hospital that are trying to give each
other like these like early Explorer
like after people are sick and they have
the antibody and then you're injecting
yourself with that dead cells that's how
like vaccines and [ __ ] are made well
that better [ __ ] to do like don't you
got some [ __ ] organizing your garage or
like some [ __ ] papers you need a
shred like that's not and I'm so curious
how the transfer is happening is it like
can you just bomb it in my mouth or like
I mean like what is the whole scene the
office episode where Dwight is talking
about how he wants to get exposed to
[ __ ] so then the whole office yeah find
someone else that is my philosophy
though I tried to get exposed to a lot
of things and be a little bit dirty or
whatever yeah I mean like before this
whole thing because I thought that
what's not chicken pox worked when
you're a kid they have chicken pox party
for kids they just I believe I got a
vaccine for that so
you're not supposed to you're still
super useful to get it no you can get a
vaccine because a modern era you can get
a unless you had chickenpox like it was
horrible
yeah so my brother was in high school
right and my brother's a big [ __ ]
bully and I had this favorite stuffed
animal like a rabbit stuffed animal this
[ __ ] was in his room
God [ __ ] caught my stuffed animal
rubbed all over me and then I caught it
damn just like that yeah what a dick
crap I love that guys wait there's
chickenpox like a mild form of smallpox
I think so I was very dangerous if
you're an adult and you get it yeah it
is very very dangerous
yeah yeah I think I mean I think I got
in then I went to the doctors and then
they injected me or something
it was the most well vaccines don't work
after I think it has to be before but
anyways I don't know but I was just like
itching so I just remember scratching
the pink cream that turns white you you
missed out bro dude you didn't do it no
cuz I got the vaccine you know like the
vaccine they won't let you go to school
if you listen when you're a kid yeah
well why didn't ya
why didn't they have the vaccine before
I don't get it like I don't know that's
why no no we're resilient all right word
Gangstar anti-vaxxer you guys how long
the chickenpox like a week I don't
remember no I know I I remember I got
them because my feet were really itchy
and like I had bumps on the
[Laughter]
you ran a lot but I mean I really feet
are pretty stinky yeah why it's because
they started offering the chickenpox
vaccine in 95 Wow
11 years old I was born I'm from strong
no you might have gotten a vaccine no
maybe that's why they have millennial
one and millennial too
did you know that they split up the boy
and that makes more sense now we imposed
chickenpox whenever I think of people
having chicken Falls adjusting her
friends when they like duct-taped oven
mitts on their hands so they can't
scratch themselves
did you and you guys have to do it you
know like tricks to not scratch yourself
I was a kid so I was scratching
everything I had eczema I was constantly
scratching like I needed some crack and
my nephew is like that dude like he's
always scratching cuz he has eczema and
then like while you're having a
conversation with them it feels like
you're talking to a crackhead over here
I'm like why do kids talk to me as if I
know who the [ __ ] they're friends they
always do that [ __ ] yeah more so at the
bone man I took it and then the monkey
came and I went to the zoo with him he
had chickenpox and eczema at the same
time Marcelle her friends I had
chickenpox and eczema at the same time
but chickenpox was [ __ ] worse he was
way worse than eczema
[Music]